medical marijuana is now legal in 16
states plus the District of Columbia I
am Nick Gillespie with reason TV we are
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and we're
talking to Rob Campea the executive
director of marijuana policy project Rob
thanks for talking to us good to be here
give us the quick rundown of what is the
state of marijuana legalization in
America we've had our best run of
victories ever recently we legalized
medical marijuana in Arizona in November
of 2010 and then this past spring we
improved the medical marijuana laws in
Maryland and in vermont and we legalized
medical marijuana in delaware so as a
result medical marijuana is now legal in
16 states plus the District of Columbia
let's talk about District of Columbia
it's legal but nothing's happening right
so how typical is that that a state like
New Jersey or DC legalizes medical
marijuana but then you know it doesn't
get into the patient's hands so New
Jersey and DC are different in DC it is
happening it's just slow so the DC
government is going to be issuing
permits to five dispensaries and ten
growers and then hundreds of patients in
the next couple months in New Jersey
it's actually being blocked by a hostile
governor and that will probably end up
in litigation it's something for
libertarians to think about Chris
Christie seems pretty good when it comes
to talking to teachers unions not so
good when he's talking about giving
life-saving drug or life enhancing drug
to answer page that's right Christie is
if you support him and you're getting
half a loaf of the libertarian agenda
and if you support a Democrat you're
getting the other half of the loaf and
you're not going to be fully satisfied
with either of the two we were evil look
fine all talk about that in the context
of national politics because Barack
Obama when he was elected people thought
they were elected somebody who's going
to be you know rethinking the drug war
he said as much he's been terrible on
the medical marijuana issue on pushing
DEA raids in California in other states
what's going on with that and is he
losing people on the left because of his
medical
marijuana steps yeah he's certainly
losing people on the left because he's
just been flip-flopping all around and
if I had to actually give you my opinion
as to what I think is really going on
it's that you know Obama is the CEO of
what is essentially the largest company
in the country called the federal
government and so it's hard to actually
manage millions of people simultaneously
and so what he's doing because he and
his chief of staff have limited time
they're only focusing on the big issues
but Eric Holder said early on that they
weren't going to be doing this type of
stuff yeah I'm not saying there hasn't
been a flip-flop I'm skeptical that
Obama is sort of scheming actively on
this I think what's happening is that
it's not a high priority issue and it's
not paying attention and so then these
bureaucrats who are running the DEA and
so forth are getting to call their own
shots in 2010 California had a marijuana
legalization ballot initiative which got
a fairly surprising forty seven percent
of the vote was that a good thing for
marijuana legalization and what are the
prospects come 2012 I think it was not a
good thing for anyone who donated a lot
of money to that campaign but for those
of us that donated zero dollars that
campaign it was a good thing because it
did move the ball forward you know
getting forty six and a half percent is
the high water mark for any initiative
in the history of the country to seek
the end of marijuana prohibition what
about in other states like Colorado is
looking to push something like that
possibly Nevada a couple other places do
you think that what are the prospects of
a marijuana legalization ballot
initiative or bill actually becoming law
in 2012 well the Colorado initiative
that you mentioned is actually our
flagship project so I actually think
that it's more likely than not that
we're going to be able to pass that
initiative in Colorado the reason I say
that is that the polling Colorado on
this initiative is currently at about
fifty percent and support is increasing
in Colorado over time combined with that
is a Colorado is actually a swing state
in the presidential election when you
have a huge voter turnout in a swing
state during a presidential election
that means that there's a lot of young
people coming out to vote who otherwise
wouldn't vote and that's actually good
for any marijuana initiative in addition
we're going to have money on our side
and the opposition is probably not going
to have real money on their side which
is the case basically with every
statewide marijuana initiative I guess
the hardest thing in that is going to be
putting up with all the Rocky Mountain
High
drugs well you know I think the people
of Colorado already used to this joke so
we might actually be impervious okay
well that's very good are there other
ballot initiatives or law you know
initiatives that you're looking forward
to as we go into the I watermark of the
presidential election it's highly likely
there's going to be a initiative to end
marijuana prohibition in Washington
State there might be another try in
California but it's unclear if the money
is going to be there and then in terms
of medical marijuana the state that's
most likely to do an initiative is
Arkansas and that's just a question of
whether we could quickly raise a hundred
thousand dollars for that and then Idaho
would be also another medical marijuana
initiative state so we're looking at
minimum one but probably more like four
initiatives in November 2012 all right
Rob Campea of Marijuana Policy Project
MPP you're at MPP org thank you very
much for talking to us thank you for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie